[Applause]
[Music]
coming to you from the historic
largo theater in hollywood it's
conan i'm andy richter
tonight jane lynch and now
here he is conan o'brien
thank you
thank you very much uh welcome to
tonight's show
jane lynch love her is going to be
joining us
and let me begin by saying we are
celebrating christmas
tonight on the conan show that's right
why you ask are we celebrating christmas
because we thought it over
and the way things are going it looks
like we might not make it to december
25th
i love christmas and i want to get my
christmas this year
i just don't trust that it's gonna
happen
you know every year andy what do you
think isn't this the way to go
yep might as well yeah remember how
you've always made fun of me you're like
why do you keep that elf suit in the
trunk of your car all the time
paid off you know what you're right i
didn't think you needed it in your trunk
of your car all the time but andy it
came in
real handy yeah as you can see all our
cardboard cutouts
are in the christmas spirit all of them
yeah that took us
uh that took us three hours and for some
reason
six hundred thousand dollars to put the
hats on those i suspect some sort of
union shenanigans but no i'm not asking
any questions
this is my uh my hat company's first
order
well congratulations andy that's right
tonight our show is a christmas show
because i just don't think we're gonna
make it to the actual day
december 25th let's get it in now
now of course no holiday celebration is
complete without a little christmas
music
that's right i've thought of everything
here to provide that for us please
welcome
the los angeles mass children's choir
[Music]
and just so you all know i too am being
careful i've got my christmas mask right
here
these are going to be big this year
isn't that great i love this
these are going to sell like hot cakes
what do you think andy uh i think you're
going to make kids cry
you think it's scary yeah it's kind of
like you're eating santa
no nature i'm vomiting up a santa i ate
two hours ago
yo well once you tell the kids that
that'll be fine yeah
anyway let's check back in with los
angeles mass
children's choir
[Music]
[Music]
me man those kids have a lot of heart
they do they sound like [ __ ]
[Music]
but they've got a lot of heart merry
christmas kids
yeah just hoping you didn't stay up to
watch the show
hey let's check back in with those
wonderful
los angeles mass children's choir
[Music]
it's the masks kids it's not you
although there are two of you that i
think well anyway let it go